good health now sponsored by partners in
primary care
partners in primary care might be new to
town but they're already helping our
local senior community stay
well especially during the holidays
here's how
so partners in primary care is a senior
focused group of medical clinics
this is our south nellis office which is
located on nellis and vegas valley
we have five other locations um all
throughout the las vegas valley that
will be opened by the end of 2020 and we
have two additional locations opening up
in early 2021.
i think all of us want to you know
deliver better care to the seniors here
in las vegas valley
and that's really what we're here to do
we know that as we age and as we get
older we have different health care
needs than
people who are younger right we have
more you know the
more chances of having diseases like
diabetes and heart failure
so it's really about addressing the
specific needs of seniors
they often have you know limitations in
mobility
and you know they may have specific
needs that you didn't have when you were
younger so it's really about focusing
on the changes we have as we age
[Music]
eating is still such an important part
of the holidays right it's something we
all enjoy
but we still want to be mindful and make
sure that we try to maintain some
healthy habits through the holidays
you know what i would recommend is you
know when you're building your plate
it's so easy to build with those
you know the sides that are you know
high in carbs and sugars
but you might want to add some other
things like fresh vegetables and maybe
fruit
to kind of have really much more of a
complete meal
keep away from the high sugary high
fatty foods
you can have parts of that little bits
of that but you know be mindful of the
entire composition of your plate
if you drink before your meals like some
water you may actually consume less
of the of the foods we're trying to
avoid you know at the meal time
not that we can't have those foods but
we want to you know keep it to
kind of limited amounts maybe not go
back for seconds
because we all understand how an
important social event
and everything that that meal times are
during the holidays
you know during these difficult times i
think you know have a great holiday
keep your gatherings small but you know
reach out to those that you love and
and stay connected so you can go to our
website at partners in primary care and
see the individual
phone numbers for each of our clinics or
you can go to seniorfocuslasvegas.com
and learn more all about us and kind of
how you can get in contact with us
for more information call 702 623
623-3774
or visit seniorfocusedlasvegas.com
las vegas now we'll be right back